when you picture drones and you see
these things on the news all the time
it's always a drone somewhere in the
Middle East usually of course and Yemen
or something firing and and usually
killing innocent people and double
tapping and all that stuff that we talk
about all the time here but you know we
are getting drones here and they're
gonna be delivering our packages and
they're also gonna be stealing your
Wi-Fi and figuring out what's on your
phone yeah let's let's take a look at
some video of a new drone that's coming
out that's a hacker he's using
technology installed on a drone to grab
cellphone information from people below
this technology has been used on
cellphones and laptops one day it could
be installed in a larger aircraft think
helicopters or small planes and down the
road and yeah I've seen lots of devices
it must be the people walking down the
road you can also see your usernames
passwords credit card information and
get this in some cases your home address
yeah so that's why we talk about drones
all the time because we're doing it over
there but to loosely quote George Bush
it's gonna end up coming over here I
mean look even if they're not going to
be shooting us which Rand Paul has
talked about you know you're gonna walk
outta out of 7/11 they're gonna drone
strike you so even if it's not that
level this is pretty scary stuff because
we know that they're taking our
information already and the metadata and
all that but now that we're gonna have
drones flying around they're gonna have
access to all this stuff well it's the
same thing that's been happening I mean
people have been creating these you have
fake Wi-Fi hotspots and stealing
people's information the difference now
is that it's mobile and these little
quad copters that are being used in
photography and used in videography
they're inexpensive and it's easy it's
now mobile and that makes it more
terrifying but this technology has
existed it's one of the prices sadly
that we have to pay for the convenience
of using our phones to Bank using our
phones for email using laptops and
things like that we it's it's it becomes
our responsibility to be aware that
these things do happen and we have to be
really careful with how we approach
Wi-Fi with our cell phone devices it
it's existed this has happened before
it's just now like I said it moves
around and it can it can get more
information more quickly but if you
think about it I mean I work in a
business that's all about online videos
I mean that's what I talk about all day
long and I find the people behind them
it's not hard actually to find all of
this information I can do it in ten
minutes just with Google searches and
looking through Facebook and looking
through the things that people post and
Twitter feeds and Instagram feed you
think about the nine minutes you'll be
able to save when you have your own view
that's the thing
Jimmy who do you fear more do you fear
just the hacker the guy that's gonna do
this or do you fear the government doing
this which do you think is actually
worse for us
you know I mean I yeah of course I worry
about both of them but I guess I'm more
worried about the government that seems
cuz because they would be shielded from
prosecution things like that they can
yeah yeah I would be Bawra framing this
is I don't you know they say privacy I
don't know I mean what are we supposed
to do they it's I just assumed that they
know everything about me at all time it
doesn't matter what browser I used to
surf the web or whatever they're gonna
get it if they want it and it just seems
like somehow we've it's a lot were
through the looking-glass right it just
seems over now and your idea of privacy
is done this life of being connected we
we like the way the world has a lot of
people do they like that everybody's
connected but that's the other side of
it that's the the price we pay of it
because we were living our lives on line
all of that is accessible and not just
by drones like that's the thing people
are really scared because they're named
drone has this you know it's instills
fear in people's hearts but it's already
happening it has been happening every
time no I was never a waiter or in a
restaurant but I always thought about
like when you use a credit card to pay
and they used to do the click thing and
they would have all your information
right there any person who's a waiter or
waitress had you're in for your credit
card information on them and yet we
never worried about that line they could
have stolen it and used it anytime they
wanted so is that a little bit of
something decent about this that maybe
our information has been out there all
along and I'm saying no because I know a
friend who wouldn't he wouldn't buy a
plane ticket using the internet because
he was afraid to put his credit card and
the internet I'm like so when you call
them up it just goes into their computer
you tell me telling it this yeah yeah
are you gonna say if so I yeah I mean I
guess you know we've I guess she just
crossed your fingers and just be glad
that nothing has happened so far as
technology increases we just have to be
more
where we just have to continue to stay
aware of how to protect ourselves and
then businesses also have to step up to
the plate and protect with their you
know and and credit card companies do
that now they say that you're not
responsible for fraudulent charges the
problem though is that we as consumers
end up paying the price for that because
the bottom line is affected by how much
money they lose to fraud all the time we
have to be informed consumers we have to
be we have to protect our own
information but we also have to be aware
and keep ourselves safe because they're
more of our information is accessible
than we think and we're the ones putting
it out there are you saying you don't
read the fifty page thing when you sign
up for iTunes you don't have them you
don't have your team of lawyers with you
sitting there going through well Beth I
don't know if you want to sign this
because right nobody no one has the time
to do that because we connect everything
through art we live our lives online
yeah
final point on this I think the through
the looking-glass I think is the perfect
way for this are we in a really
interesting time right now where for a
while we had all this stuff let's say
for the first ten years of mobile phones
and the internet we all had it
we all loved it everyone found poor and
everyone was excited now we're in the
through the looking-glass part which I
don't know how long it's gonna last I
feel like we're in like a three-year
thing here of everyone going [ __ ] we had
all this stuff we loved it but we also
hate it and now what's the what's the
other side you know I mean am I giving
you some time giving you a little
esoteric there is yeah I think that it's
actually going to continue to to
increase there's a great book that came
out called the circle it's David Eggers
and it's this book that's written about
the concept of total transparency total
transparency the idea is that the
company that he created in this book
represents a company kind of like Google
and as people you you're always going to
have the people who say I don't want
anymore technology I don't want anymore
to happen but the way that the world
moves you end up almost being forced
into it in the book total transparency
means all people in government
constantly having cameras on them all
people everywhere constantly having
cameras and broadcasting that to
everyone and the weird thing about it is
is that as you read something like that
you can see that something like that
could easily happen because as we move
forward with all of this technology we
get more accustomed to it we get used to
it it doesn't feel as scary it doesn't
feel as intimidating and we keep moving
forward with it will will we stop will
it stop I I didn't think we needed more
technology in like 1992 you know and
then suddenly here we have this world oh
we have a phone that has more technology
in it than the Apollo that went to the
moon so you know we keep we we we don't
stop it we keep buying into it we keep
moving with it because we have this
whole concept that it's better to be
connected it's better to put our lives
out there because we can you become
narcissistic in a way can't stop
progress bring this home Jimmy well you
know what they say on the definition of
a narcissist is that someone who's
better-looking than you